[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y los acompaño desde casa por la
pandemia de kobe 19 iniciamos fuera de
la tierra para referirnos a un hecho
histórico por primera vez un helicóptero
vuelo de forma controlada en marte
estamos hablando del ingenio y pti que
despegó sobre vuelo y aterrizó en el
cráter yesero del planeta rojo fueron
tan sólo 40 segundos de vuelo marciano
el pequeño helicóptero ingenuity despegó
con éxito desde la superficie del
planeta rojo flotando en el aire a unos
3 metros de altitud antes de descender y
aterrizar sobre el cráter pero en marte
una noticia que fue recibida con vítores
desde el centro de control en california
informa que ha realizado el giro el
despegue el ascenso el vuelo
estacionario el descenso el aterrizaje
los datos del altímetro confirman que el
ingeniero ha realizado su primer vuelo
de una aeronave con motor en otro
planeta el helicóptero de propulsión
solar y tu historia al ser el primer
vuelo con motor controlado en otros
neta pero tal hazaña no podría haberse
hecho sin su compañero en marte el rover
perseveren que facilitó la comunicación
con el equipo de misión en la tierra
debido a los casi 300 millones de
kilómetros que separan ambos planetas la
nave fue diseñada para ejecutar
instrucciones de forma autónoma
tenemos tres objetivos que están en
línea con los objetivos de la agencia de
la nasa
el primero es demostrar aquí en la
tierra que es posible realizar un vuelo
con motor de control en la fina
atmósfera de marte y ya lo hemos hecho
william de el mismo engineer y envió una
secuencia de imágenes mostrando su
propia sombra proyectada sobre la
superficie y el verse viviente también
captó un vídeo de la cabeza
el éxito de este debut podría llenar el
camino para nuevos modos de exploración
en marte y otros destinos del sistema
solar volvemos a la tierra y ahora
hablamos de kobe 19 vamos hasta israel
mucho se ha mencionado la llamada nueva
normalidad post pandemia y este país
parece estar acercándose velozmente a
ella las imágenes que vemos parecen de
antes del brote pero no es así el
gobierno autorizó que la mascarilla ya
no se use
libre un año después de que la medida
fuera implementada obligatoriamente
actualmente somos los líderes mundiales
al tratarse de surgir tras el
coronavirus por lo no nos desharemos de
las mascarillas es decir dentro de los
edificios de los salones de clase las
usaremos afuera podemos quitarnos las
pusimos aún es recomendable utilizarlas
en sitios concurridos pero en general
adentro de sus puertas afuera pueden ser
retiradas se estima que actualmente un
56 por ciento de la población del país
ya se encuentra completamente inmunizada
lo que permite tomar una decisión tan
trascendental como ésta que por fin le
da un respiro a los israelíes de estar
sin la mascarilla por primera vez en
tanto tiempo se siente raro pero es
bueno es como la mascarilla ha sido una
parte de mí por un largo tiempo así que
estar sin ella
sin embargo tienes que usar el
interiores
es difícil molesto pero si es lo que se
necesita para acabar con esto haremos lo
que podamos a pesar del optimismo las
autoridades han pedido cautela
principalmente por las nuevas variantes
del virus y han solicitado a los
ciudadanos que se mantenga la distancia
social el coordinador de respuesta
nacional a la pandemia advirtió que pese
a la gran cantidad de vacunados y a los
830.000 israelíes que superaron el virus
se necesita llegar al 75 por ciento de
la población inoculada ido recuperada
para conseguir la llamada inmunidad de
rebaño no obstante es importante
reconocer el éxito que ha tenido esta
nación que llegó a registrar 10.000
casos diarios y actualmente las cifras
rondan los 85 nuevos contagios cada día
dejamos de israel y ahora nos centramos
en las vacunas chinas contra el co beat
que se vieron envueltas en una gran
polémica hace algunos días
gafo director del centro chino para el
control y la prevención de enfermedades
asegurado en una conferencia de prensa
que los fármacos no tenían una tasa de
efectividad muy alta por lo que era
necesario mejorarla posteriormente
explicó que no hablaba de las vacunas
chinas sino de las vacunas en general
que se han desarrollado contra el virus
pues las declaraciones generaron
controversia principalmente entre los
ciudadanos de varios países por temor a
que las vacunas chinas nos sirvan y
porque se han conocido casos en que pese
a haber recibido de las inyecciones las
personas se contagian ya sea con vacunas
chinas o de otros laboratorios en el
mundo pues para aclarar estas dudas
chile realizó un macro estudio enfocado
en la eficacia de la vacuna coronaba
desarrollada por el laboratorio chino
sinovac la efectiva para prevenir cobit
sintomático es decir infección con
síntomas cierto fue un 67 por ciento
efectiva para prevenir ingresos
hospitales en general a cualquier cama
fue 85 por ciento 89 por ciento fue la
actividad la efectividad para prevenir
el ingreso a camas de unidades a
unidades de cuidados intensivos y
finalmente el desenlace de muerte
también tuvo un número importante de
prevención que es alrededor de un 80 por
ciento se trata del primer gran análisis
en población real sobre esta vacuna y no
de un ensayo clínico donde se mide la
eficacia en voluntarios y en condiciones
específicas cerca de 10,5 millones de
personas participaron en este estudio
realizado entre el 2 de febrero y el
primero de abril recordemos que chile
aplicado alrededor de 13 millones de
vacunas y el 90% han sido de corona vaca
finalizamos en madrid donde se encuentra
el velázquez tech museum una experiencia
inmersiva y de alta tecnología que busca
acercar al público a la famosa obra las
meninas de diego velázquez se trata de
un recorrido por ocho salas de
instalaciones interactivas de esculturas
femeninas proyectadas con vídeo mapping
y acompañadas de música barroca y ritmos
contemporáneos
a ustedes gracias por su compañía
recuerden que pueden repetir este y
otros programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]